for years people have asked how we make
our videos so let's finally talk about
it
how to make a kodz gazat video in 1200
hours or more
[Music]
the first things first we need a topic
our potential topic list is already
endless and every time we research
something it grows longer so we just
work on whatever we find exciting at the
time this could be something serious
fascinating personal or just really
stupid the variety is half the fun we
want to explain complicated things in an
easily graspable way and make sciency
topics fascinating and beautiful but we
also want to tell stories and express
how we feel about the universe from time
to time
laying the foundation script
our research Begins by reading books or
scientific papers and by talking to
different experts who point us in the
right direction we want to have a
fact-based worldview and our videos are
trying to reflect that so we often have
to change our view on an issue while
working on it usually after a few weeks
of researching we start writing a script
begins with a rough first draft that's
then Rewritten and edited over and over
again to make sure we don't misrepresent
something we ask experts to fact check
and correct us writing is the bottleneck
for our videos and very hard to speed up
usually finishing a script takes between
a few weeks and literally years to
complete
let's visualize illustration
when the script is ready we begin
sketching out the video we try to think
of visual metaphors transitions between
ideas and decide which scenes need the
most attention on average 200 panels
need to be Illustrated in Adobe
Illustrator
although we have built up an
illustration Library we still do most
illustrations from scratch to give our
videos a more unique look
the general idea is to find the right
images to the words in the script to
explain as clearly as possible while
also having interesting things to look
at
also here we include all the visual
Easter eggs
in total two to three illustrators spend
8 to 12 weeks illustrating the video
[Music]
now it's my turn narration
when the whole video is Illustrated the
narration is recorded in a small
recording studio on a Neumann tlm-103
microphone and Pro Tools it's important
to keep the flow so I try to get one
version done and then go back through
retaking paragraphs and sentences until
they feel right and a full version is
ready
it's alive animation
now the scenes and audio need to be
animated we make things move in Adobe
After Effects and recently we've begun
experimenting with Cinema 4D the first
thing to do is take the Illustrated
scenes apart and organize them the
hundreds or thousands of parts are then
imported into after effects
character is rigged so we can move them
more naturally
[Music]
aside from a few plugins that help us
save time every single thing that's
moving on screen has been moved manually
so two to three animators animate scene
after scene for about eight to ten weeks
in total
[Music]
ending on a high note music and sound
design
the final step is the music every song
is original music composed to the
finished video to create a unique
atmosphere and to highlight the
important parts
you can listen to all of the songs on
Soundcloud and Spotify
the icing on the cake are the sound
effects
many of you might not even really notice
them which is a shame because they
really add an additional layer
so try watching a video with headphones
if you want to get the full depth of it
all of these steps happen in parallel
since we usually work on two to four
videos at the same time in various
stages
what we haven't mentioned are the
countless revisions and edits every few
days we sit together and review our work
and tweak it until it feels just right
and that's it at least 1200 hours for a
single quotes art video as you can
imagine making videos for thousands of
hours is a big team and then putting
them on the Internet for free is a weird
business model
over the years we've relied on a number
of different things to stay afloat
commercial work for ngos startups or
corporations
sponsorships and grants by companies or
organizations
we struck a deal with Funk from German
public broadcasting to revive the German
Channel and with Wix to start a Spanish
Channel but the reality is we can only
do what we do because of you our two
most important sources of income by far
come from your direct support
merchandise and patreon so if you want
to help us stay afloat and keep making
more videos you can directly support by
getting something beautiful from our
store or by becoming a patreon and
joining the bird Army don't feel
obligated though watching engaging or
sharing our videos is already helping us
a lot
but if you want to support us directly
thank you so much you're making our
videos free for everyone
you are enabling us to practice and
improve to stay independent and to work
on ambitious projects that would be too
scary or too big otherwise
cause arcs did not start with an end
golden might it began as a personal
project because it felt good to make
something with time and love and this is
still true today making these videos is
our goal doing the work every day and
getting better to make science beautiful
and interesting thank you so much for
sticking with us for seven years and
from our first subscriber to the 10
millionth this journey has been so wild
and so much fun and we can't wait to
share the stuff we're working on right
now with you in a year or maybe two
we want to make meta videos like this
from time to time now if you want to ask
us questions that you want us to answer
you can do so on Reddit Link in the
description
[Music]